bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
petite vidéo les fossiles vivants pour
les nuls où nous allons apprendre à
reconnaître un véritable fossiles
vivants d'infos alors internet et
foisonnant d'arguments plus ou moins
moisissures les fossiles vivants les
arguments moisi venant des
créationnistes qui prétendent comme
harun yahya dont vous pouvez voir le
site en ce moment qui prétendent que
évidemment le monde entier est peuplé de
fossiles vivants comme le coelacanthe
qui sont exactement similaire aux
espèces modernes et que du coup bah rien
du tout n'a évolué bon j'ai envie de
dire qu'avec des arguments comme ça même
homo sapiens est un fossile vivant
puisque au final on trouve aussi des
fossiles d'homo sapiens dans le registre
fossile des fossiles qui ont presque 300
mille ans mais bon si vous regardez
l'homo sapiens 10 à 300 mille ans donc
homo sapiens de erfoud si je me rappelle
bien le nom de ce site
donc voilà si vous regardez le homo
sapiens de erfoud il a quand même pas
grand chose à voir avec l'homo sapiens
moderne a le front est vachement plus
incliné les volets sus orbitaire sont
vachement plus gros et le menton est
vachement moins prononcé donc au final
oui ça s'appelle homo sapiens mais bon
ça ressemble pas quand même à l'homo
sapiens moderne
donc voilà internet est rempli de gens
qui prétendent que les fossiles vivants
sont la preuve que l'évolution n'existe
pas comme harun yahya et comme harun
yahya je leur souhaite de finir en taule
pour viol de mineur
voilà un dont karim ghallab j'ai envie
de dire ces retours de carmat ah ah
bref n'en faut pas se réjouir du malheur
des autres mais quand même
donc tu peux voilà quand il envoie ses
gros livre atlas de la création bien
prose ailettes à des écoles moi ça me
donne juste envie d'étrangler des bébés
chats donc voilà ça c'est son via
d'épargné un bébé chat enfants mettant à
ouyahia en taule donc voila moi je vais
vous apprendre aujourd'hui à identifier
les vrais fossiles vivants défaut que
vous soyez créationnistes ou pas ça peut
vous aider
ça peut aider les créationnistes à
trouver des vrais fossile vivant ça va
à pouvoir aider aussi les
évolutionnistes à contre-argumenter des
fossiles vivants qui n'en sont pas ou à
arrêter de contre argumenter des
fossiles vivants qui en sont vraiment
éventuellement donc et comment va-t-on
faire ça et bien on va se pencher sur un
outil qui s'appelle la paléobiodiversité
et paléoenvironnements database et que
vous le taper correctement pas comme moi
vous tombez sur deux pages la
paléobiodiversité wise as on va regarder
d'abord la paléobiologie data base la
vraie le site principal
mais c'est un site qui est extrêmement
difficile à utiliser donc déjà parce que
la barre de recherche qui se trouve en
haut ici est extrêmement tatillonne dans
paléobiologie database donc si vous
faites la moindre faute de frappe
le site ne trouvera rien mais par contre
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec
paléobiologie la tablette c'est l'outil
explorer il explore en anglais ce que si
vous tapez un fossile au hasard comme
par exemple bâtonnets d'apprendre le
coelacanthe à celle 1 quand donc c'est
là quand tu ce qui n'est pas le genre du
coelacanthe moderne ou coelacanthe
moderne c'est la team est rien mais
c'est là quand vous voyez vous tapez
coelacanthe us et le napeo biology
database vous trouve les fossiles de
sela quand tu sais à peine vous pouvez
zoomer donc voilà vous pouvez voir qu'il
y à des fossiles qui ont été par exemple
trouvé en allemagne en angleterre la
couleur correspond à l'âge
donc vous voyez que ça s'allume en bas
là il ya un coelacanthe du permien
coelacanthe us du permien là il ya un
coelacanthe us du carbonifère et si vous
cliquez dessus
voyez il ya là il ya la provenance qui
s'affiche vous cliquez sur la provenance
et là vous avez les fossiles
enfin de la référence pour
de la description du fossile donc c'est
ça que ça la paléobiodiversité registre
de tous les fossiles qui ont été
enregistrés et publiées dans la
littérature scientifique donc c'est pas
ça n'a pas la prétention évidemment de
décrire de d'enregistrer tous les
fossiles du monde mais ça a au moins le
mérite d'avoir enregistré tous ceux qui
sont publiés et ça c'est quand même un
outil assez formidable vous voyez là il
ya encore du coelacanthe us du trias hic
ici donc du trias donc ça c'est un outil
assez formidable qui a été développée
depuis les années 2000 et maintenant qui
a atteint un point où il ya suffisamment
de données à l'intérieur pour dire que
ça devient exhaustif
ça devient franchement exhaustif donc
mais nous on va pas utiliser cette
interface là on va utiliser notre
interface qui est faux cils works
pourquoi parce que la barre de recherche
est beaucoup moins tatillonnes dents
fossiles works que dans paléo biology
databail mais voyez vous voyez en hausse
et écrire c'est directement connectée à
paléo biology database mais la barre de
recherche ici et beaucoup beaucoup moins
tatillonnes que dans que la panne et aux
bailleurs logique à tabac donc voilà
allons chercher alors à la recherche de
fossiles vivants on tape on fossile
vivant dans la barre de recherche google
et puis bah nous allons demander à paléo
biology la table s'il s'agit bien de
fossiles vivants parce que nos principes
d'un fossile vivant je le rappelle c'est
qu'il ya du vivant mais il faut que ce
biais que cet être vivant et aussi des
fossiles qui soit exactement similaire à
lui donc des fossiles de la même espèce
enregistrés dans le registre fossile et
on va voir si les signaux fameux
fossiles vivants soit disant sont
réellement des fossiles vivants alors à
athènes et espère une page sur les
espèces planctoniques avec le
coelacanthe donc espace pont chronique
c'est juste fossiles vivants mais avec
un nom un peu plus joli
enfin ou peu plus pompeux surtout plus
scientifique
mais au final est-ce que le coelacanthe
est une espèce pan chronique qui
injustement espèces pont chronique ça
veut dire que cette espèce le
coelacanthe moderne en fait laissé la
carte modernes y en a deux et
complètement conservé depuis le registre
fossile jusqu'à l'heure actuelle alors
coelacanthe
lorsqu'on va faire c'est qu'il nous faut
le nom d'espèce il nous faut le nom de
genre et d'espèces dont la page anglaise
de wikipedia me conviendra nous faut le
genre le nom de genre et le nom d'espèce
donc le nom de genre et le nom d'espèce
où est ce qu'on va les trouver on va les
trouver on va les trouver
là il ya tout laisser là quand on veut
seulement le moderne donc le west indian
ocean coelacanthe voilà donc le
coelacanthe moderne
l'ati mejia quelle taille donc l'ati
mejia callune alès ça c'est le nom
d'espèce du coelacanthe moderne c'est le
premier qui a été trouvé
normalement il y en a une deuxième
espèce qu'on regardera après de ces
cinquante moderne ou est-ce qu'il est
peut être dans les lattes immery délà de
la page précédente
se sont ils font partie tous les deux du
genre la team à abobo la ménade owentis
donc on ira voir celui là donc d'abord
allons voir la team herria calluna
sourcils works va chercher la team
erignac hanouna et apparemment aucun
fossile enregistrés alors on va juste
taper la team herria toiture juste le
nom de genre donc l'être le monde dort
c'est la team aerial le nom d'espèce
c'est qu'à lui nay cannes une maille ou
qu'elle eut mené si vous préférez voilà
pas de fossiles non plus alors pour vous
prouver que quand même ça marche
normalement on va taper tyrannosaurus je
vais vous montrer ce que c'est censé
nous donner normalement la fossiles wars
la paléopathologie la tabasse voilà
quand vous avez des fossiles voilà la
page que c'est censé vous rendre ça vous
renvoie à toutes les classifications et
à la distribution voilà hadjadj donc
l'âge des fossiles 70 à 66 millions
d'années et la distribution donc crétacé
du canada voit la chine mexico russie
etc
donc ça vous donne l'âge des fossiles et
leur localisation et
quand on tape là qui mejia et bat ça
nous renvoie rien du tout ça nous
renvoie à que chip octobre
voilà la team herria quelle taille neuf
singles rien du tout pozzo ben
donc c'est même pas la peine d'aller
voir mais nadeau et m6 au final puisque
la team et rihanna à 0 fossile donc le
coelacanthe c'est un fossile vivant
qu'il n'a aucun fossile
voyez ce que je veux dire alors oui il
ya d'autres membres de la famille des
coelacanthe décès la cantine forme qui
sont fausses il
mais ils sont très différents du
coelacanthe moderne on va aller voir par
exemple rebelles à trice la regardait
rebelles à tricyle a rien là il a pas du
tout la même gueule que le coelacanthe
moderne pour ça c'est une reconstruction
mais je veux dire le voyez la forme de
la queue qui caractérise nos belles
actrices un rien n'avoir avec avec celle
du célèbre noyé forktail coelacanthe un
coelacanthe avec une queue fourchue
donc c'est quand même la caractéristique
principale de rebelles atrix donc non le
coelacanthe n'est pas un fossile vivant
ou même une espèce pont chronique ni
l'un ni l'autre ça c'est bullshits assez
bullshit sp sport chronique c'est nul à
certes c'est pas une espèce pont
chronique parce que tout simplement elle
a pas de registre fossile cette espèce
latimer yaka lyonnais et mesdames
ennadre au n 6 non je me rappelle plus
mais bref aucune des deux n'a de
fossiles connus
donc on peut pas dire que c'est une
espèce une espèce qui a pas bougé depuis
le registre fossile en maintenant
regardons les mules limule libellus
polyphemus bongo c'est bien on va on n'a
pas à chercher mais il y en a d'autres
après donc là il ya plein espèces tenez
on ne donne beaucoup d'espèces pour les
limites donc on va aller chercher on va
aller les chercher avait bien encore en
plus des nautiles donc on ira voir les
nautiles juste après donc les lits mule
nîmes ulus polyphemus on va taper juste
dix minutes pour l'instant juste
histoire de voir s'il ya du lit mulhouse
dans le registre fossile
vas-y paléobiologie database va chercher
[Musique]
ni minus toujours pas de registre
fossile
il est pas beau il est pas beau votre
peau s'ils vivent là quand même nos
occurrence of limule us in de database
aucun fossile publié de l'imus connu à
ce jour
alors vous êtes content d'être venu 1
là vous êtes en train d'apprendre que
tout ce qu'on vous nomme des fossiles
vivants depuis le début en fait ils ont
aucun fossile connu dac hyp les us alors
taquipneu us c'est le limule du japon et
des philippines c'est le genre du film
de lee mule du japon et du philippines
aucune occurrence dans la paléobiologie
database car si ce corpus indonésie non
c'est vachement diversifié quand même
pour un fossile vivant les lits mullings
trouvait pas que pour un fou un fossile
vivant serait quand même en droit de
s'attendre qu'il y ait une diversité est
égal à zéro
non vous croyez pas qu'un fossile vivant
ne connaîtrait pas de phénomène de
spéciation corps car s'ils ne supportent
plus ce n'est pas du tout enregistré
dans la paléobiologie database donc dans
ce cas là on peut on peut se dire
qu'effectivement il ya peut-être des
fossiles de carcillo ce corpus mais que
du coup c'est juste que le genre
n'existe pas dans la database peut-être
choquer car si nos ce corpus car si nos
scores plus bas n'ont définitivement pas
bref un elle ressemble à un groupe
fossiles les trilobites bah voilà donc
ça ressemble vaguement alors on va dire
que c'est un fossile vivant voilà c'est
ça qu'on vous écris ça ressemble
vaguement c'est un fossile vivant
surtout pas papa pompier
je fais juste un petit aparté de montage
sur les lits mule alors il n'y a pas de
fossiles de représentants des limites
moderne dans le registre fossile ça ne
veut pas dire évidemment qu'il n'y a pas
de fossiles de la famille délit mule
dans le registre fossile
évidemment qu'il y à des représentants
de la famille daily mail mais ils ne
sont pas directement relié au leem une
moderne
il ne leur ressemblent pas par exemple
ici vous voyez une lime une moderne à
gauche et à droite ici vous avez une
limite fossiles et alors ce que je vous
montre sur ces photos en fait ce sont
les pâtes daily mail moderne qui n'ont
pas de branchies vous pouvez voir qu'il
ya une pâte avec des pinceaux les pâtes
sont avec des passes au bout mais n'ont
pas de branchies attaché alors que sur
le fossile vous voyez des pâtes ici en
bleu auxquelles sont attachées envers
des branchies donc des fossiles de limur
oui il y en a mais ils ne sont pas
semblables aux espèces modernes ce ne
sont pas des fossiles qui représente les
espèces modernes ce sont des espèces
différentes
voilà nautilus pompe lit au milieu donc
le nautile pareil un grand grand
classique des fossiles vivants wallon
voir si le nautilus compile us à un
registre fossile on commence par les
nautiles nautilus
vas-y va nous chercher le nautilus alors
nautilus l'a déjà vous voyez qu'il ya un
peu plus de matériel là là déjà on
trouve quelque chose d'un peu plus
intéressant donc nautilus avec un
registre fossile a aura donc nautilus à
un registre fossile
on le retrouve dans le quaternaire donc
des fossiles très récent miocène
oligocène éocène donc des fossiles
cénozoïque valeo cède aussi du crétacé
et aussi jusque dans le permien à là on
a peut-être un fossé là on a peut-être
quelque chose qui qualifie fossile
vivant mêlant mon heure seulement en
train de regarder le genre nautilus on
regarde pas l'espèce l'espèce du nautile
moderne nautilus pompilius elle est là
on clique dessus et on est redirigé vers
la page du nautile moderne et là c'est
pareil le remuant le nautile moderne
nautilus pompilius la vraie le vrai le
team moderne celui là il a un registre
fossile dans le quaternaire et dans le
milieu scène alors je rappelle les
hominidés
ils ont aussi un registre fossile qui se
limite au quaternaire et au milieu cède
donc le nautile c'est pas plus un
fossile vivant qu'un hominidés donc nous
a en réalité on n'est pas honteux on est
tout autant des fossiles vivants que le
nautile à ce jeu là le registre fossile
des nautiles il va pas plus loin que le
milieu scène en fait que le le registre
fossile du nautile moderne
alors après oui les nautiles idée si
vous allez dans la famille de thil idée
là par contre vous allez voir la liste
est gigantesque
voilà la honda du registre fossile qui
descend aussi loin que le permien mais
c'est la famille voilà dire que les
notes ils sont des fossiles vivants
c'est comme regarder tiktaalik où un
camp toasts et gatwick tilhos dégâts et
dire qu'il ya 300 400 millions d'années
on avait déjà des trucs avec deux bras
deux jambes et deux yeux
des humains c'est des fossiles vivants
bah oui voilà les nautiles c'est pareil
vous regardez une ressemblance
superficiel et puis vous dites cela
fossiles vivants
ben non c'est pas un fossile vivant le
note il ya le registre fossile du
nautile il a rien de particulier n'a
rien de il a rien de particulier par
rapport au registre fossile des humains
alors peu bâtonnets on va retourner voir
revenir ya donc le sénat quand il a pas
de faux cils l'éliminons pas de fossiles
les cafards je pense que je vais pas
faire les cafards parce que honnêtement
je crois que la famille des cafards ya
juste un demi milliard d'espèce le
cafard voilà non non on va taper cafard
m'équiper dia voilà parce que je pense
quoi
j'aimerais pas faire des conneries comme
ça voilà les blattes arias voilà il ya
4000 attendez attendez je vais me voir
voilà il ya trente espèces de cafard
associés aux eu mal à associer à
l'habitat humain
out of forensic à hauteur forte hausse
en six ans droite donc il ya quatre
mille six cents espèces de cafard dont
associé à l'habitat humain je vais pas
taper les 4600 espèce de cafard enfin
mais encore une fois
vous chers amis créationnistes je
m'adresse à vous si on parle de fossiles
vivants
ça veut dire que quelque chose n'a pas
évolué et or s'il ya quatre mille dix
ans
s'il ya quatre mille six cents espèces
et qui a eu spéciation quelque part et
s'il ya eu spéciation c'est qu'il ya eu
évolution donc cette voie là jeudi à
4600 espèces c'est laquelle le fossile
vivant là c'est la ken de toutes ces
espèces qui est un fossile vivant donc
jute
voilà zut je vais pas me taper mais vous
avez compris l'idée donc prenons une
espèce quelque chose de mieux bien le
capi alors l'okapi est un fossile vivant
ça c'est nouveau okapi et bien cherchons
le capi - le capi c'est quoi son nom
d'espèce okapi okapi de son petit nom
d'espèce au cap ja jones tony on va
chercher au kkk tia l'asie paléobiologie
database offre nous ta lumière au cap ya
donc le genre à un registre fossile dans
le quaternaire et le pliocène le
pliocène c'est plus jeune que mios est
donc c'est encore moins un fossile
vivant le genre est encore moins un
fossile vivant que l'espèce note il est
alors okapi à jones tony on va voir et
okapi à dow jones tony à un fossile
connu dans le coin quaternaire du congo
2,5 millions d'années voilà 2,5 millions
d'années ces australopithèques husson
non même pas non je dis des bêtises
enfin il ya encore des australopithèques
à 2,5 millions d'années mais 2,5
millions d'années il ya aussi le genre
homo qui est déjà là donc c'est pas
surprenant de voir des okapis 1 2 du
même âge donc non le nom à bunia
le capi n'est pas un fossile vivant bref
voilà c'était là paléobiologie database
le meilleur moyen de savoir s'il existe
oui ou non un registre fossile à votre
fossile vivant donc c'est votre fossile
vivant n'a pas de fossiles c'est juste
un vivant voilà donc on arrête de
tergiverser voilà et puis on se
renseigne
avant de clamer haut et fort que les
choses sont des fossiles vivants parce
que sinon bah on dit de la merde voilà
donc que vous soyez quand je le redis
que vous soyez créationnistes
évolutionniste voilà vérifiez toujours
que le truc dont vous parlez est un
fossile vivant un vrai et pas seulement
et pas seulement un truc dont les gens
ont l'habitude de dire que c'est un
fossile vivant parce que ça les arrange
parce qu'ils ont appris les choses comme
ça mais ils ont appris des trucs faux
voilà un fossile vivant ça une
définition bien particulière un
espacement chronique aussi ça une
définition bien particulière et il se
trouve que aucun des jeans codé
coelacanthe délit mules ou de tous les
trucs qu'on a checké aujourd'hui ne font
partie ne remplissent la définition de
l'espèce pont chronique ou de fossiles
vivants
voilà en réalité fossile vivant c'est
plus une métaphore qu'autre chose c'est
à dire c'est un animal donc impossible
vivant c'est une espèce qui appartient à
un groupe qui n'est plus représenté que
par une poignée d'individus ou qui a des
caractéristiques un peu qu'on considère
comme étant primitive par rapport à nous
ce qui est franchement anthropocentriste
ou bien bref à ce jeu là en gros tout
finit par être des fossiles vivants
c'est vous ne vous n'avez qu'à checker
le guide critique de l'évolution 1 le
grand livre de lecointe donc dans le
guide critique de l'évolution dont je
vais vous affichez la couverture si
j'arrive à la trouver voilà il ya eu
tout un passage sur les fossiles vivants
et vous y verrez qu'il y aille au moins
cinq définitions différentes
vous pouvez aussi si vous avez le
courage allez sur notre chaîne car nous
avons fait une vidéo sur les fossiles
vivants
donc stop science faux cils vivant voilà
donc on a fait une vidéo sur les
fossiles vivants alors c'est une vidéo
qui a 5 ans donc elle n'est pas joli
elle est un peu datés l'humour et
franchement date est aussi mais on y
parle de toutes ces définitions du
fossile vivant d'une façon un peu
particulière je le conçois mais on parle
de toutes ces définitions du fossile
vivant on parle de tous les exemples de
fossiles vivants qui ont été données et
au final on conclut bas que ne
correspond à la définition de fossiles
vivants absolument rien du tout ce qui
est exactement ce qu'on vient demain
aujourd'hui grâce à la paléobiodiversité
merci à tous et à une prochaine fois